Alicia how you doing
oh you're muted you gotta take that uh
line through the mic at the bottom of
your screen there you go
how you doing
I really enjoyed uh hearing I I honestly
haven't read your book and I'm just kind
of being introduced to your channel so I
definitely appreciate your approach and
how you handled you know the whole
locking down women I think that was
really nice if you just said yeah does
that make sense
absolutely I I 100 agree that when at
least for me when I'm in a relationship
it's that person and no one else
um you know and and I think that that's
a good thing and a bad thing
um I think that it gets to the point
where you're like I don't realize that
there's other people out there and then
if it ends then you know you're kind of
in this like not in an obsessive state
but you're like no it almost feels wrong
to think about somebody else in that
manner if that makes sense yeah it's
it's not something that you want to
enforce on a woman I mean if a guy's
ever tried to set boundaries around you
um it's generally uncomfortable for
women is what I find it's it needs to be
a choice right it's like okay look
um like one of the things that I
encourage guys to set a boundary around
is don't deal with women that keep guys
from their past around right so if you
dated somebody for
a period of time obviously your
instrument with them I'm not good with
my girl going out to lunch with
you know Fred or whatever it's like look
it's as simple as
I don't take women seriously that behave
like that like I can't be in a
relationship with somebody that does
that so if you do that and that's your
choice you can kind of go so it's not an
enforced boundary it's like a choice
that you have to make so it's it's a
it's a careful dance that you have to
walk and I think a lot of guys struggle
with it because they have a lot of
social anxiety around women they're not
particularly calibrated well it's a bit
of an issue did you have a question or
did you want to challenge me on
something tonight like what did you want
to chop up on this show
I just kind of ran
off something like
okay it kind of just crossed paths and
uh you know I just kind of wanted to
tune in are you single are you in a
relationship right now like what's your
story
[Music]
you're gotten out of a six-year
relationship okay
um it ended pretty badly so um you know
kind of like what we're talking about I
was I was all in I was invested exes
were blocked didn't have guys on social
media didn't go out on the weekends you
know I kind of sheltered myself to be
this
um
not introvert but I guess that's what
you would call it I went to the gym I
did the groceries I did clean the house
I managed it all and kind of put him
first put him through his version of
school while you know we had both been
out of undergrad
um and when it was his turn uh he he
backed out
his turn to just kind of take over so we
were together for almost six years
um in September uh one of his co-workers
had reached out to me
and was like trying to hit on me and at
first I thought it was a good joke
because it was like his best friend and
um I was like that's really
inappropriate like I will be telling my
ex
um and he was like well your ex is
cheating on you with his partner
so business partner
they're in enforcement oh okay so their
cops got it
right so you know I had invested six
years we I we had just been in contact
with the mortgage broker we were gonna
get a second dog we had a house together
um we had it all together right things
weren't great things were really bad
um he could never make up his mind there
was a lot of red flags but I was
invested right like I was doing it you
know I always accepted the apology I
always looked at him first he was the
alpha
you know that kind of like structure and
I was just there like to put it all in
the place to be that Homemaker to be
that like friendly figure
so while I agree with like the being
with one person and being like invested
in them and you know it for me I like to
be in my feminine
um
I feel like
I don't know I guess I'm kind of
confused that like at what point does
the man back out on that like if you
know you're all invested like I'm doing
everything I can like you know I
considered myself to be attractive and
consider myself to be in you know
Fitness was was he invested in this
partner of his like they would go out
and date they would uh see each other
you know beyond just work
to my knowledge he was always home if he
wasn't at work I knew his schedule
um was she in a relationship too she was
engaged
they just had a baby yeah yeah oh and
they just had a baby yeah so he didn't
meet her until April of 2022
and you know he kept coming home to me
and being like I do not like her I don't
feel safe working with her
um she always um
uh I didn't I don't know I see I I was
just told by his close friend his male
close friend who I had you know been
around been out with
um that he was cheating on me with the
co-workers so I had got suspicions and I
had started asking questions
and I had looked through his phone he
handed it to me I looked through his
phone
um I didn't see anything I checked his
Apple watch when he was looking uh he
had put me in this crazy mindset and so
one day he's in the shower
and he's playing music and I hear it
stop for like a little second and it's
it's like a thing when you take a
picture on Snapchat it stops the music
for one brief second so I kind of like
moved the curtain and I'm like what who
are you taking pictures for in the
shower and he's like get out you're
crazy like doesn't say anything just
calls me crazy which was a common theme
for him for me you know when I asked a
question
and
um yeah so I I had been like okay like
who are we Snapchatting like what's
going on he's get out so he walks the
dog back in then I come to find out he's
like it's just my co-worker
okay like why are we Snapchatting that's
my cohort let me use Snapchat my
co-workers in the flower like that's
weird yeah
and so I figured that out and then
um he ends he cuts it off right there
there's no explanation the next couple
of days is it with you or ends it with
her me like whole turkey we were
literally in the middle of about to buy
a mortgage three days before we had just
renewed our 15 month lease from our
townhouse we had
um we were about to buy something like I
said were you guys talking about having
kids like a family
well that's where it gets a little juicy
so I wanted I wanted kids I really
wanted kids I invested six years I mean
I'm only 25 but at the same time like
you know I wanted it right I was like
this is the man for me I'm loyal this is
all I want it's beyond me why women try
to wait into their 30s and 40s it's just
nuts but carry on yeah
and then you know have the kids and I I
was going to be my own boss I was gonna
be able to take care of my things do
what I wanted so I was sad he was like I
don't want kids I don't know if I
believe in marriage I don't want to be
tied down well lo and behold things get
a little toxic when the breakup happens
he starts popping out of the house doing
things
um so I move out a couple weeks later I
left all my furniture my name's on
everything everything's financed through
my credit
um you know I left it all and my name
was supposed to be taken off turns out
it wasn't so come to find out
um it's confirmed in December I found
out on Christmas Eve that they're
actually together that she was like
living in my house
um they were like raising her baby
together
oh no so he even cooked himself what a
dummy yeah so
I don't know what happened
I was like okay by the way well if you
don't
so
that's what I found out and then um a
couple months later my friend facetimes
me and she's like I have something
there's some really bad news
and she's pregnant
okay my babies with me yeah okay okay so
I mean look
um
life kind of has a way of showing you
these things and you're and you're and
you're better off for it now than what
you would have been trying to push
through it
um
I mean I'd like to hear his side of the
story too but at the end of the day I
would love to hear it
no they always say there's you know
there's her side and there's his side
and there's truth somewhere in the
middle you know between those but
um like as far as any advice for what to
do in a scenario like that is let that
[__] go I mean if you're carrying around
any kind of resentment or guilt around
that one of the problems that I see with
women as they get older is I don't see
them dealing with trauma that that that
they come across and it's one of the
arguments a lot of guys make for dating
or women not just because they're more
youthful beautiful and fertile but also
they have less baggage there's less of
heat he hurt me he cheated on me he he
whatever me you know
um because what I've seen people do and
it's not just women to do this but it
seems to be that women like to do this
more than men from my experiences that
they'll take bricks you know if I can
use a visual they'll grab a Sharpie and
they'll write he cheated on me and I'll
throw it in a burlap bag and they put it
on their back and this is an invisible
bag and this is invisible brick uh you
know he hurt me he whatever he pushed me
down the stairs you know he was whatever
you know he he ignored me and they and
they keep filling this bad with bricks
and they carry it around like it's a
badge of honor like it's pride and if
there's any advice that I can give you
is if you have any resentment or guilt
because these are the two most negative
emotions you can have as a human once
towards yourself one sword somebody else
is get that [__] worked on yeah right
because the last thing you want to do is
bring that to the guy that might be the
father of your kids that you build a
family with and you've got that
resentment or you have some guilt in
there somewhere and it's like he could
be a totally normal great guy but
because you've got that bag of bricks
hanging over your shoulder and you're
still carrying it around like it's a
prize you don't have a proper functional
type of relationship and people have to
learn how to take that thing and just
put it down and walk away from it
because that's really all that you have
to do I can tell there's a little bit of
um there's a bit of a burn you know with
the way that you're telling the story
which is normal right how long would
this happen
so we are and
a Timber
um since then I have not dated I have
not in Iraq I mean I've like talked to
people I've kind of recently just got
into like being open to the idea of
dating but I've just completely ghosted
anybody that seemed interested in me
I've just been working on myself working
on my school those are guys that were
interested in you I'm sorry what was
that you ghosted guys that were
interested in you yeah
yeah because I didn't talk to males in
six years so I was like I gotta start
interacting you know like it's not it
can't just be me and my girls anymore
like I do need to be open to the idea of
at least male friends yeah so so I mean
like where some women go with that
sometimes they go to dark places where
they start reading like why men love
[__] or some one of these like
ridiculous books that encourage women to
not be nice right because guys aren't
nice because guys do bad things to women
sort of thing and like I said earlier
you know men and women are better
together than they are apart right so
whatever you know is causing you to
ghost or not talk to these guys and some
of them might be normal you know like
one of them could be a perfectly normal
human being that would be a great father
to a family sort of thing
um figure out what what that resentment
or guilt happens to look like and deal
with it and I'm not a qualified person
to help you dig through that but all I
really do is I talk to people have
conversations I hold up mirrors you know
I show them stuff that I'm seeing I
think people you know in the live show
right now are in the chat probably
seeing they'll probably leave a comment
below but
um you get the idea right like for you
to be able to move on you have to let
that [__] go because the last thing you
want to do is carry that into the next
relationship and the last thing a top
shelf guy wants to deal with is a gal
that brings her baggage from the last
relationship into his life yeah and
that's what I've been saying you know
I'm like my friends and you know people
in my life are like why aren't you
dating why aren't you talking to guys
like you're young you're in your crime
and I'm like I don't think anybody
deserves to have any ounce of what I
just had to carry or like I'm dealing
with and I'm not really dealing with it
anymore this was just like the talking
point of like how I am in a relationship
and how I do my all you've always got
some good material Alicia there's a
there's a lady
um she's got a book called um mating in
captivity Esther perel is her name
I would start with that
okay yeah she's she's a uh she's a
well-trained psychotherapist she's in
TED Talks
um I mean she does it from the feminine
perspective so I think you hearing about
a lot of these uh relationship woes the
way that she you know defines it the way
that men and women deal with this sort
of stuff whether it's cheating betrayal
um you know like any number of those
ways that you wanted to find it
infidelity she has a nice accent she's
like infidelity uh check out her stuff
it's actually pretty good
perfect yeah I
appreciate all right take care thank you
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out